a look at ottawa this morning where for
the first time ever the prime minister
has invoked the emergencies act it is
tuesday february 15th we are canada's
morning show with that shot there you
can still see protesters on parliament
hill you bet good morning everybody in
ottawa is where we begin this morning
with this unprecedented move by the
federal government in response to those
ongoing protests let's bring in global's
abigail beeman who joins us from the
nation's capitol this morning abigail
good morning and first off what powers
does the emergencies act give the
federal government
good morning so there are a few things
on the table the prime minister saying
yesterday that law enforcement was
having significant challenges in the
ability to carry out its job and as such
part of the part of what's on the table
for the emergencies act is more tools
for law enforcement specifically rcmp
will be able to enforce municipal or
provincial rules of course we have you
know three different layers of police on
the scene here in terms of ottawa police
ontario provincial police and rcmp as
well as other
local detachments that are that are
helping out so more powers for the rcmp
on scene another element that's that's
very specific but relevant here is that
police
sorry the federal government can direct
services so specifically uh we're
looking at the federal government being
able to direct tow truck companies to
tow some of the vehicles here something
that has been a big challenge for the
city of ottawa getting tow truck
companies who are willing to come down
here and move some of these vehicles so
we will see how that
rolls out and then a very important
element is the financial implications
here uh talking about uh freezing uh
bank accounts of anybody who's involved
in the protest as well as the layer uh
looking at crowd crowd funding platforms
making them register with fintrac and a
number of other things in that realm the
finance minister deputy prime minister
christopher freeland uh saying yesterday
that this is about following the money
so
will this actually work to end things
and does the pm have the buy-in he needs
i know a couple of provinces have said
this isn't necessary
that's right so that's the big question
will this end things how will things end
when will things end uh
the the a lot of people looking at that
finance element as saying that that
could be uh the real the the real thing
that makes a difference here i've been
out speaking to protesters every day
that i've been down here
including yesterday all day everybody i
spoke to it doesn't matter what you
throw at them they say that they are
staying it can be a fine it can be a
rest now if it if it becomes clear that
there could be some longer term
financial implications and we're still
waiting to understand uh you know the
real details here of what this means
because the emergencies act itself is
very time limited and targeted but if
there are broader financial implications
i remains to be seen whether that indeed
will have an impact on some of the
people who are here uh we know
christopher freeland also said that that
companies who have trucks here will have
their insurance suspended uh will be
impacted as well uh so that remains to
be seen but all of the protesters that i
have spoken with are saying that that
they're staying and that there's
essentially nothing that can that can
make them leave in terms of your
question about buy-in so waiting on a
vote in the house of commons and the
senate needs to vote as well and we'll
see what the outcome is there we know
that the ndp appear to be on side with
the liberals here conservatives say they
need a bit more time to look at the
details but it accused the prime
minister of inflaming things inflaming
tensions uh stigmatizing protesters
rather than de-escalating the situation
so we will see how that unfolds and you
mentioned premiers as well the prime
minister has to consult with premiers
before invoking the emergencies act we
heard from doug ford yesterday very
supportive of this move and of course we
know ontario launched its own state of
emergency
last week but a number of other premiers
have spoken out you know jason kenney
saying that this was not necessary scott
tweeting about it last night that he is
not on board there are a number of
provinces pushing back and people in
general who feel that you know the
threshold has not been met the very high
threshold that you need to meet for the
emergencies act to be invoked
all right abigail just finally there was
a seizure of weapons yesterday at the
coots border in alberta what more can
you tell us about that
so we know that police have made 13
arrests in couts that there was
more than a dozen uh uh
weapons and a lot of ammunition that was
seized on scene a lot of concerns uh
obviously about the very clear danger
that that that could have posed in couts
waiting to see exactly what what the
situation is on the ground but it sounds
like it is uh scaling down the size of
the protest there in this morning that
that some trucks are continuing to leave
but waiting to get an update as to how
that's actually unfolding on the ground
all right abigail beeman in ottawa with
the very latest thank you